servus kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute spielen wir
micro et genauso an wie unsere zeiten
begrüßung baumarktes mitgemacht alles
richtig viel spaß hatten wie findest du
geil heißen dass man auf den weg gemacht
aber der mond ist immer gleich zeiten
auf dem platz machen
auch übrigen sollte heute kam auch
wieder eine folge check in ab da haben
wir einiges angekündigt für die zukunft
so falls ihr euch interessiert wie das
bag weiter geht gerne mal abdecken und
weil es nicht so spannend ich hab so 6
100 coins geholt max ungefähr 700 und
dieser hey check er mit uns in der runde
sie welten gleich sehen hatte 1400 cosco
hole so und das witzige war dass
deathmatch deswegen springt zwar hinter
dir was kosten entstanden was du hast
alles offen es 300 weg 2
drei levels wahrscheinlich auf das
kostüm vor 3362 schwertwalen 9,75 junge
was richtig krank bei mir wird noch berg
angezeigt aber ich krieg schaffen das
dankeschön dieses spiel am anfang auf ok
aber da sind zwei losheimer kennt
jemanden der liebermann abi gemacht weil
ich mein glaube ich wollte ich einfach
glaube ich nicht sie bereiten
alles passt mein schwert
ja ich glaube oder da habe ich dann
kriegst du damit auch kaum jetzt zu viel
oder wie wenig respekt bei dem junge
junge junge gottéron schnell schießenden
wohl rein
hey was bringt bringt nichts ich musste
abstand halten ich genommen sonst nie
von sich und bösen kampf da unten
ok herczeg fünf herzen sie aber ihr das
bringt nichts da reinzugehen
das ruckzuck wieder vorläufig erkauften
sucht das weite
dollar um auch einer soll das aber der
dritte der drei herzen dass du schon
anständig report alles klar dargestellt
so dann bin ich jetzt aber schnell
regeneriert das war wichtig und jetzt
vier pfeile auf dem power 22 bogen
kämpfe auf drei herzen und hatte nur
eine co2-steuer probieren
spiel mal ein bisschen defensiver bringt
nichts den scheiß longbond junge kicker
nothberg what the [ __ ] is gesehen kann
opel bekommt aber auch am morgen einmal
recht
ja ich kenne jetzt doch plötzlich hat
einen fall 22 treffer für ihn gegeben
ich probier auf den aufs schiff zu gehen
oder so warum hat niemand so viele leben
nein nein
wie kann das leben haben tatsächlich
wieder leben und vor allem kein städter
ich glaub mal lieber er hat mich viel
erleben
wahrscheinlich viel leben für das schiff
gehen du mich nicht verbiegen
ich kann jetzt schiefgehen euro junge
knapp acht prozent brennan regenerieren
intention
da kommt er kommt noch an kommentiert
doch ein objekt teilweise richtig
komisch mal motto ich hab noch nie
protection zwei die pflanzen kann mir
jetzt so also seine richtig im ganzer
schlagabtausches gerade das 600 punkte
darf er 1000 tiere und dafür schlagen
und ganz gut gerade muss man sagen dafür
liefern wir den guten kampf führte du
hast sie im herzen tragen lassen ich hab
seit ich habe sehr gut sein aber er hat
nicht so ein starkes schwert sage ich es
auf der extra herzen hat er nicht so
stark erschwert und vielleicht extra
herzen ja wieder nach weil du nicht
dauerhaft na klar er als ob so was gibt
man sie kaufen für 60 vorwärts 60 points
what the [ __ ] die op ist das denn
und die hat man dauerhaft hey das ist ja
richtig und fair
alter schwede ja gut dann habe ich ein
problem habe ich ein richtiges problem
junge was ist los mit dem die kassen
steigt ständig für sein wie der
wachtmeister dimpfelmoser alter young
boys geht mit du kriegst keinen schaden
10 herzen und verliert nicht den wind
schlägt ja überhaupt keine herzen
jetzt hat er gerade ein herz hören oder
er hatte wirklich 14 15 herzen verliert
jetzt erst lockte das kann halt einfach
ein extra hätten die wurden nicht
angezeigt ich habe viele herzen sehr gut
aber es ändert nichts
das gleiche da frag ich hab' ich habe
junge das ist die bitterste zeit meist
nur befristet jetzt kommt wieder
ich hab ihn zu enden lass dich ruhig
regenerieren
diese entziehen dass sie nicht an land
machen
ich kann diesen fight aber einfach nicht
gewinnen ein tag zu viel mehr herzen das
system die kicker kommen ist ja und er
hat einfach eine feier aspect red ich
meine ich glaube ich mache mir schon
mehr schaden
was tut die vertreibt sein
ich habe um gold
die alterswehr ist jetzt kommt wieder
lasst mich euch generieren hier habe ich
in 20 minuten auf port 2009 noch
entschieden
ich denke schon noch ganz ein dass die
erste wurde einfach standard caps in
peking mit vielleicht macht
wunderbar
jetzt gewinnt